we've accepted that invention and
innovation comes from engineers and
comes from R&D labs and large companies
and it's time to change that my name is
I am there I'm the founder and CEO of
little bits when I was growing up I was
very good at math and science and I was
a tinkerer and I was always taking
things apart so I spent my undergrad
doing engineering but for me didn't feel
like there was any room for creativity
and so it wasn't until I graduated and I
discovered MIT where I realized the
power of technology when you combine it
with creativity and my mission became
how do you bring this kind of access to
technology to people that are outside
engineering that are designers that are
artists that are kids could you make
electronics easy could you make them
accessible could you make them fun but
if it is a platform of easy to use
electronic building blocks for creating
inventions circuits that are pre
engineered and preassembled so that you
can get started making your own
inventions without having a background
in engineering I realized that there is
a big opportunity to be able to effect
change with kids to affect change with
creators that are usually constrained by
technology or their knowledge of it so a
little bit has been growing faster than
I even imagined in September 2011 I
started with one kit 10 bits and one
team member today
we have about 70 different bits we have
110 little ebooks team members we have a
retail store that we just opened so you
can make something like a wireless robot
or you can make a bubble bot a machine
that makes bubbles through a
so it's playful but also functional
inventions that get kids excited you
have about 2200 schools that are using
milli bits at various different classes
the world is changing constantly and for
kids we need to prepare them for careers
that haven't been invented yet so what
we need to do is really help people
become lifelong learners so that they
can continue to learn and reinvent
themselves